environnement avec cette nouvelle étude
inquiétante qui démontre que la fonte
des glaces dans l'antarctique et bien
une réalité une accélération que la
planète risquent de payer cher dans le
futur florence mecque et si
l'antarctique devenait un jour un
gigantesque puzzle de glace cet immense
continent perd les eaux au cours des 50
dernières années
à certains endroits le thermomètre a
grimpé de près de 9 degrés ces falaises
proche de l'amérique du sud en sont les
premières victimes
l'eau s'écoule dans les fissures de la
glace elle arrive à fractionner des
blocs large comme un département
français
sur cette photographie l'art il est un
tas puis il avait une rapidité
surprenante elle se disloque événement
sondés ils ont caractéristiques de la
période récente ça nous renforce dans
l'idée aussi que ce réchauffement est
bien lié à l'action de l'homme à
l'augmentation l'effet de serre de
récentes données scientifiques
confirment que l'antarctique perd plus
de glace qu'il n'en reçoit sous forme de
neige
il emmagasine pourtant 70% des réserves
d'eau douce de la planète à l'autre bout
de la terre au pôle nord on n'est guère
plus optimiste
les scientifiques soupçonnent le
groënland de fondre doucement le volume
de glace déversés dans l'atlantique
aurait quasiment doublé en cinq ans ces
changements perturbent les animaux qui
doivent se déplacer de plus en plus loin
pour trouver une banquise où se reposer
se reproduire les ours polaires sont des
mammifères aquatiques mais ils ne
peuvent pas nager près de 300 km et
c'est justement ce qui correspond au
retrait de la glace sur la côte nord de
l'alaska
ces territoires glacées sont encore mal
connus grâce au satellite les
scientifiques peuvent désormais observer
les changements au fur et à mesure qu'il
se produise